[Music]  Pharrell Williams vows to the people of  Manchester duets with Miley Cyrus and  Marcus Mumford during Ariana Grande's  one love Manchester benefit concert  the 44 year old singer got emotional on  stage during Sunday's concert in  Manchester England I'm bowing because  despite all the things that have been  going on in this place  I don't feel or smell or hear or see any  fear in this building  all we feel here tonight is love  resilience positivity and you know what  I hate to be corny but it actually makes  me uh marcus mumford joined Pharrell  during his hit get lucky and sang happy  alongside Miley Cyrus  all the proceeds from the one loved  concert will go to the victims and  families affected by the bombing at  Ariana Grande's concert nearly two weeks  ago  that left 22 dead and 116 injured  [Music]